it's nine o'clock this is sky news
welcome to our show where i interview
people who have something to say about
the world today and how it's changing
they'll be from politics sport business
entertainment public life or there'll be
everyday people caught up in the events
of our times i'll be putting my
questions to tonight's special guests
[Music]
good evening in a moment that shocked
the world it was revealed this week that
the united states supreme court could
vote to overturn abortion rights in the
u.s the revelation happened in an
unprecedented leak from the court itself
the implications could see many states
effectively banning abortion i'll be
talking to the veteran american civil
liberties lawyer and fighter for women's
rights gloria allred in case after case
she's advanced the feminist cause is her
lifetime's work now in shreds
also tonight can any good come from a
crime of unimaginable brutality
claire thrussell's two children were
murdered in a fire started by their
father
now she fights on their behalf for
victims of domestic abuse she's helped
change the law already but she says more
much more needs to be done
and regardless of your views if you're
british the royal family take up space
in your media your culture even your
mind the journalist tina brown has spent
years trying to peer behind palace doors
she says that for 30 years there's been
a non-stop power play with the queen
herself holding the reigns as we look
ahead to the platinum jubilee i'll ask
about tensions in the family and what
might happen when the queen's reign
draws to its clothes
jack and paul were typical young boys
until eight years ago when jack was 12
and paul was nine
their father killed himself and them
in a house fire
their mother claire russell vowed to
protect other children caught up in
domestic violence she has successfully
helped to pass the domestic abuse act
but her work is not done as she tells me
in an interview we did earlier this week
and a warning this interview has a
description of how jack and paul were
killed which people may find distressing
claire first up thanks for coming to
talk to us today
and telling us your story
i want to ask you about the events that
led you here your campaign to try and
better protect children from domestic
abusers but but let's start with your
boys jack and paul
what were they like
they were the typical
boys
very
outgoing confident
it's funny you you bring them up both
exactly the same and yet they're so
different
jack was
a lot more caring
a lot quieter
paul was cheeky
full of fun full of energy
jack was a musician
he
loved music it ran through his veins
like
water down a stream and he played the
trumpet
and until he started playing the trumpet
he was quite a
introvert quite quiet boy yeah but
playing the trumpet absolutely changed
his life yeah he found that it was okay
to try to do something and
it's okay to fail
paul
was always trying to be like his brother
paul was a runner he was a sprinter
in fact i think he could run before he
could walk
and when you saw him run
it set him free
150 was his favorite
distance
and he loved the glamour of the track
but he used to light up from inside and
he'd say whatever's happening at home
on that track nothing can catch me
nothing can touch me and claire your
boys would have been jack would have
been 20 now and paul would have been 17
and do you sort of imagine it that
jack might have been a musician and paul
might have been a a sort of sprinter
yeah their futures were taken away from
them and
it's really an open wound that i keep
picking but it's bleeding anyway
i see his friends and
i saw one of jack's friends the other
day and he's got a beard and it's
a case of that's what jack could look
like now um
all the
all the marks the proms
learning to drive
leaving school
going to university that could have been
them and that should have been them can
i go back to if it's all right with you
to your experience and and the events
leading up to you your boys
losing your boys
you met the boy's father when you were
25 i think
did you notice any red flags about him
back then or did he woo you and
was a very loving partner
back when i met him there were no
mention of domestic abuse um
the term love bombing
he sent a rose to my works every day for
three weeks until i said i'd go out with
him okay there was something i didn't
like about him and i'd said that i
wouldn't go out with him but
you know after three weeks you kind of
feel
sort of
a little bit special maybe a little bit
more interesting than
normal yeah now i would say to any young
person that that's actually love bombing
and you're being conditioned
to be loved
it's coercive it's a bit controlling
you left
your ex-husband
after 16 years that must have felt
like a relief was it for you
well to be honest that's when the danger
escalated so it wasn't really for you as
well for all of us okay um
because that's when he lost control
right
when of you
yeah and the boys
because the boys didn't want to see him
but as you said
actually the situation deteriorated
because
the boys had
unsupervised visitation with their
father even though you fought that
in the court can you just explain to
viewers what happened so in the july i
was forced
to go to court and begin residency order
proceedings against him
and that's when
the fear and oppression just carried on
he was allowed to
intimidate me in the court i had to sit
in the sim
waiting area and he was sat just across
from me
and what people don't realize about
family courts is they're not protected
like a magistrates in a crown court
and in those courtrooms
perpetrators are allowed to cross
question
their victims
and even though he had a barrister there
he hurled insult after insult across
that room it was just a board room i was
just four seats away from him
and in the second court hearing he
actually went for me so we had to move
away from the doorway
and when we got into the courtroom
the judge
said that uh
even though he's shown and displayed
this aggressive behavior
he still could have five hours
unsupervised access
to his children a week so the boys went
back
was it to your house
yes
we'd only been divorced two weeks
by the 22nd of october
and
uh when i walked in
call it instinct call it
worry i always worried
about the boys i said the phones are on
the table they need the phones every
time they go to see the dad
and she said he was like picking them up
today
so
i was actually debating about going down
there and and giving them the phones and
if i had done i'd have been able to go
in and get them
that haunts me to this day
but instead
i had my tea and it could only have been
15 minutes
and the doorbell rang
and for some reason i didn't want to
answer it
call it an instinct to call it
a warning
and when i opened the door
there was a local police officer
and he stepped back under the light
and i looked at his face
and the first thing i said was what has
he done
now i live in a small village he knew
jack and paul i'd pass them at school
i'd say to him morning
he'd say
morning
and the look on his face i knew you knew
and i said what has he done
and he said there's been an incident
and you need to come with me now the
boys have been taken to sheffield
children's hospital
so i got in the car
and we traveled at about 100 miles an
hour to
sheffield children's hospital
and he pulled into the square where the
recess rooms are
and he said go
go go
so i ran in and the first thing i saw
was
a medic doing cpr on paul and paul
you're not he was then nine you're nine
year old
and i just remember watching him
being bounced off the bed with the force
of the
cpr's not nice to see or do
and uh
i was dragged literally into a room
because i was just ready to run across
to him
and
a doctor came to me
and i could see with his face
and he said to me are you
their mum
i said yes
and
he said
i'm very sorry but we're going to let
him go now in your arms
and i said what do you mean go
and he said there's nothing more we can
do so i ran through with him
and i just scooped him up into my arms
and when people say the light goes out
of people's eyes you don't believe it
till you see it
and these beautiful blue eyes just
looked at me and they turned gray
and they just looked as if they were
looking through me
and i said to him
come on paul you can't leave
don't do this stay
but he'd gone and the nurse
closed his eyes
and i was holding on to him so tightly
and my tears were wet in his hair
and i just sat rocking him
and i went screaming because i couldn't
talk the pain
was just so intense
there was nothing yeah just this pain
and this
love and i said to him
that i loved him
and that i promised him
that no other child
would be hurt
by a parent or an adult
and i was still holding him tightly
and
the medics came and said you have to let
him go now he's a crime scene
and there were just the wrong words to
say because he wasn't a crime scene he
was yeah yeah my son my cheeky yeah full
of energy running
son that i just dropped off at school
yeah nine hours earlier and he looked
perfect he just had a scratch
down his nose and that was from where
jack had pulled him pulled him across
and uh he just looked like he was
sleeping
and i said to the nurse
don't leave him on his own he's only
nine
and the nurse said no i'll i'll sit with
him
and then
i went over to jack
and he was still fighting at this point
and they turned around and said to me
you've got a choice now
we're taking jack to manchester
so you either stay and sit with paul
or you go with jack
to manchester
it was the furthest they'd ever been
apart as brothers
they'd never spent a night apart they'd
never spent more than a few hours apart
we
we got to manchester
and uh
jack held on for five days we were 56
percent burnt
and details were coming out slow but
sure about what actually happened so
that they could piece it
together
and they worked out that
he'd actually barricaded the property
and trapped jack and paul in the attic
he was found in one corner of the attic
and jack had tried to escape and when
paul fell
he went back for his brother and he gave
his hand in the darkness to his brother
and he used his own strength
to pull his brother
to the hatchway
and for five days
the hospital
said i had to talk about paul as if he
was alive
because jack believed he'd saved his
brother
and jack was
only sedated he wasn't in a coma he was
sedated for the pain he must be in a lot
of pain
and um
if he knew that
paul hadn't made it it would affect his
recovery yes
so for five days i sat at his bedside
and you could tell what he could hear
because every time i spoke to him
his heart monitor went right down
he just calmed him down like hearing his
mum
just calmed him
and then on the monday
which was his
third operation
it wasn't going well
and
he'd come out and he was in recovery but
he wasn't recovering
and this nurse came flying down the
corridor
and i just ran after her she didn't even
have to say anything
and they started cpr because with burns
victims
the potassium levels in your blood
build up
and the potassium stops your heart
right okay
and jack's potassium levels was too high
so he just went systolic so his heart
stopped
and again i watched them
perform cpr on him
i knew the longer that they were doing
cpr and god they tried they tried
that less of
jack would have come back
and if he hadn't been able to play his
trumpet if he hadn't been that gentle
boy who had a
heart and courage of a lion
then who were i bringing him back for
they fought and fought
and again they turned to me with that
look in the face
and they said we're gonna have to call
it
and i scooped him up
in my arms
i promised him
i said to him that
no more
children should have to be killed by a
parent
no other child should have to say to a
fireman and a doctor and a police
officer
that their dad had hurt them and they'd
done it on purpose
and no more parents would have to end up
like me
just existing just living
not even living
nobody should have to
hold their children in their arms as
they die
and
their lives were taken
because the court said they could
i
did everything by the book
played by the rules
i told
the court in my application
back in july that he was capable of
killing the boys
cafcass
i told them not to see him
on their own because when he heard
something he didn't like
then he got aggressive
i told social services the same
kafkas ignored that
and on the monday before the wednesday
she had an interview with him in her
office
and
when she terminated the
interview he barricaded her in the
office and refused to let her leave the
room
that was never reported that was never
acted on
and had i known that on the wednesday
then i would have quite happily gone to
jail
rather than let them
go on that visit
and
jack and paul made 19 children
murdered at the hands of a known
perpetrator of domestic abuse
and now we're up to 43 children
and it's not even been 10 years
and i promised both of them that they
would be the last
tell me what your
your goal is in terms of the next piece
of legislation that you feel is
necessary to better protect children
there's a piece of legislation called
practice 12j right and it's practice
direction for children that are
suffering abuse
now i can hear people screaming it now
if we have to have legislation to
protect children who are going through
abuse
why not just stop the
presumption of contact in the first
place
this
small piece of legislation underneath
the children's act
was brought in
around parental access yes to children
and in this legislation it says it's in
the child's best interest
to see both parents
now this obviously needs changing too
only if it's in the child's best
interests and it's safe to do so
because practice 12j
is what
social services cafcass and judges
make their rulings on yeah
now
there's so much made about parental
rights
but there's this deafening silence when
it comes to children's rights
and every child's right
is to be safe and loved
and protected
one final question for you
claire
the way you talk about them
it feels to me like they're still with
you they're very much still with you you
feel that do you that they are
perched upon your shoulders
the day that i don't talk about them the
day that i don't feel them
that's the day that they die
and i will keep talking about them
and i will challenge every court in this
land i'll challenge every
lord every lady every baroness every
baronet
every prime minister
i will challenge them all
to say that they have done the best that
they can to keep every child in this
country safe
and not one of them can look at me in
the face and say that
and i will carry on asking the awkward
questions i will ask people to sign the
petition
i will ask them to sign the campaign and
i will take it back through courts again
and i'll take it to the house of lords
again
because since they ruled
that practice direction 12j didn't need
looking at
more children have died
more
and they could have made a difference to
those children
and they have to be held accountable
for that
and so far nobody is
so i'm going to carry on
even though it rips my heart in two
every day
because
they would have stood up and done the
same
for me
and
that's why
i carry on
in their names
well claire thank you it felt like a
real privilege that you shared your
story with me
and told me about your boys and told us
about your campaign so thank you so much
i'm really grateful i know that that's
not easy um thanks for telling it
thank you
claire russell they're very brave and
still campaigning hard
now stay with us because coming up next
tina brown author of the palace papers
speaks to me about the royal family the
duke and duchess of cambridge and the
future of the british monarchy
[Music]
welcome back tina brown is the former
editor-in-chief at tatler magazine
vanity fair and the new yorker 15 years
ago tina released the diana chronicles
dubbed a profound and in-depth look at
princess diana's life and death now her
new book the palace papers inside the
house of windsor tackles the highs and
lows of the royal family including the
controversy surrounding the duke of york
and harry and megan's infamous move to
the u.s
tina thanks for coming on the show and
um and thanks for sending us a copy of
this and i have been uh kept up very
late at night reading it because it's
genuinely
a really good read
and it's a page-turning drama really of
the ups and downs of the past two
decades of of royal life
and it struck me when i was reading the
book that after diana
the queen effectively said
never again will one member of the royal
family destabilize the whole institution
like the way diana and that whole
situation
and then i thought of prince harry and
andrew and it seems to me that they've
been having quite a good go at
destabilizing the institution and the
queen
well that's right and in a different way
i mean diana's destabilization was
because she became bigger almost than
the institution which was something that
had never encountered before
in the case of uh you know andrew and
harry of course uh
andrew was a was a was an explosion
waiting to happen frankly the way he'd
been carrying on decade after decade
really kind of unpoliced in a sense
about what he was getting up to so that
exploded as it inevitably would frankly
um
harry was i think the real uh kind of
unsettling surprise
in a way harry has sort of continued
his mother's legacy essentially of
throwing hand grenades
and i think that's what they found so
destabilizing about harry's they don't
quite know when another one of the the
guns is going to go off which is what
we've been seeing really ever since the
la well for the last four or five years
and i was going to come on to harry and
megan in a bit but more broadly when you
think about
the monarchy which you studied for many
many years and britain
it it seems that the monarchy is able to
adapt and it has this ability to survive
is it
is it rather like the terminator it's a
sort of something that's indestructible
do you think
it is or it's proven to be in the sense
it's lasted for a thousand years
but we are at a perilous moment i think
in this particular this particular time
because
a lot of the uh dramas of the last 25
years i wrote about was somehow
this the queen at the center was always
this still center of composure in the
storm in the storm she was always going
to sort of pull it together and pull it
out the difference now of course is we
have a very frail queen in the last
twilight years of her life
and there won't be her as the composure
at the center to pull the institution
around and keep on representing it with
the same kind of gravitas so
uh
that's much more concerning i think now
that the rocking and the boat somehow
can be
uh quelled for a while while
king charles when she will be you know
takes over and tries to say that would
be a big danger point you think in the
monarchy's survival
i think it's a very very um
unsettled point
and
charles is going to have quite a
challenge i think in sort of calming all
the troubled waters and
i think personally that the british
people will actually rally to charles
because uh you know
there's a desire i think for this
institution to continue there hasn't
been really any great potent lobby in
england to get rid of the monarchy
but it has been uh tarnished a great
deal by these last few years and charles
is going to have to figure out how to
sort of start to really modernize the
monarchy more than it has been and also
to to find a way to to kind of keep
those uh troubles that have been
assailing them at bay
i want to go through the women now with
you briefly camilla
i mean in the book what you described
really is this turn around for her that
over the decades
she's gone from this sort of villainous
comedy character to someone who's
accepted if not quite loved by the
public
what genius was behind this
rehabilitation of her or rather was it
just in your view the passage of time
well there was a lot of of genuine
professional efforts behind uh camilla's
rehabilitation mark bolland you know who
was the communications secretary for
charles right after the uh the uh end of
the camilla the end of the diana era
just as that was ending he came in and
he spent many a year
carefully strategizing the sort of
emergence of camilla but i it was always
a question i think not only of strategy
and how she emerged but once people came
to understand who camilla really was as
opposed to how she'd been demonized that
ultimately that final acceptance is
camilla's triumph because
people who get to know camilla who
really see camilla up close love camilla
so that was really i suppose what
charles knew he knew if only people knew
her like i know her they wouldn't have
the hostility to her so you know it's
been wonderful to see that i think and
you portray her in a very positive light
in the book as you do with kate kate
middleton the dutchess of cambridge
kate middleton is very much the hero of
your book
and you've spoken about the immense good
luck william had in finding kate and as
you just said has become the rock of the
family
in the book you write of her serene
empathy as you put it in in sort of
saving william
does she have any edges at all is there
any
flawlessness in this character or is she
perfection no one is perfection and i
think that the the the what i hear is
that that the kate in private is a much
more relaxed loose warm you know uh
joshing kind of fun girl woman um but
she just has decided that the
best way for her to present to the
public is in a sense by taking a leaf
out of the queen's book and presenting a
certain kind of inscrutability and she
she's very savvy in understanding at a
much more difficult time than the queen
frankly experience because when the
queen was in her early years the press
was completely a deferential i mean
there was no expose of going on behind
the scenes so she but in in this age
she's dealing with a much more invasive
press but she's found a way to kind of
control her image if you like in a very
smart way as
any kind of major movie star does so
she's very savvy at kate and not i don't
think quite acknowledged for being quite
the sophisticated strategist that she is
what strikes me in the book though too
is let's come on to megan
um
there's a sense of disdain for megan i
pick up in this book and it left me with
the impression that that you think she's
rather spoiled is that is that fair tina
well i don't think i actually don't
think that there is disdain for megan in
the book i i feel that i
i i
i actually
understand
uh
why she she she reacted as she did
how extraordinarily difficult it was for
an outsider an american to come into
this
sort of tight uh
arcane family with all of its traditions
and its history and it was an absolutely
uh for her sort of impenetrable
experience
um i think that she just didn't
realize as i think a lot of americans
certainly don't realize that actually
the royal way of life is nothing like
the celebrity way of life it's nothing
like the light like a royal or you're a
celebrity yeah it's nothing like it's
nothing like that the california uh
elites way of life it's nothing i mean
it's it's it's actually they live you
know in a very unflashy way their their
vacations are uh
you know uh
in the rain often having tramping around
you know having picnic now outdoors this
is not anything in a sense that is as
glamorous i think or as exciting or as
desirable as uh most people on the
outside looking at the glitter and
glamour of being a princess they're not
seeing that they're not seeing quite
frankly the kind of frugal threadbare
aspect of the existence tina when you
think of that couple now and speaking to
lots of people you spoke to dozens of
people for this book um do you think
that they
uh can come back to the royal family do
you think there's a way back for them i
mean some of the things that you count
you know
it feels like maybe it's it's
irreversible these rifts it does at the
moment but i tend to feel
there will be a desire to have the
sussexes back
if something can be worked out where the
sussexes are happy and a role can be
found that they can do
i think that really because i after the
death of the queen there is going to be
such a huge seismic public reaction
there's going to be you know a sense
that that of of tearing of the fabric of
this country with the passing of the
queen who for 70 years has been the only
thing we know she's on the money even
um that i think that uh there will be a
desire to have the sussex back just
because they bring
a connection to the younger
part of this nation and you know harry
was the most popular member of the royal
family and to have uh a a a beautiful
you know dynamic uh uh woman of color at
his side was actually a fantastic thing
uh for for for britain it really was and
there was a sense of great loss actually
there in the palace that that it didn't
work out uh the question is whether
megan will ever want to come back i was
going to say you can see harry may be
coming back but it's hard it's hard to
imagine it's hard to imagine megan will
want to come back after everything
that's passed but you know time passes
and it's quite possible that this this
entertainment deals that they've done
are going to not be as
glittering as
you know as they as they expect could
you see a situation where harry comes
back and megan does not that i i guess i
stick an impression no i i think that
this marriage i mean i think you know
that this is harry is devoted to her and
to the children so i don't i don't know
how it could happen but you know the
fact is that if you're a member of the
royal family you can be as boring as you
like forever and you're still going to
be at the top of the bill if you're in
an entertainment world you have to earn
uh you know your place in it by having a
hit and that's very hard to accomplish
but the next hit's going to be the
memoirs
prince harry's memory was
in september
harry how damaging could that because
you say there's a way back and i think
the the comments about kate making megan
cry i mean those things kate can't reply
to but must cut her quite deeply the
memoirs come out what does what more
revelations could happen i think that
you know your original question can they
come back i think that one of the
questions is what what is said in this
memoir
and
that's the part that everyone finds in
the family finds very hard to understand
why why harry has done that because
to have that hanging over them as a kind
of thing hanging out there of like what
is he going to say you know just at a
point when the queen is at her most
fragile
i think there's a huge anxiety about it
that was the other question i had about
the other person that does all doesn't
come back uh prince
andrew
uh obviously he escorted the queen at
prince phillips memorial service but is
there any way back for him or once the
queen isn't there anymore his
relationship with charles is very
fractious is that it for him
i don't think there's a way back for
andrew i really don't i think that
andrew thinks there's a way back for
andrew but i do not think there is a way
back for andrew and i think that charles
will have to spell that out
even more clearly
than it has been spelled out thus far
uh to see him escorting his mother uh at
uh
prince philip's memorial
was something that nobody liked the
sight of it it felt so unfortunate this
person so recently disgraced was had
sort of uh
managed to get himself into a position
where he was right right away before the
cameras escorting the most uh revered
and a woman in the world the love the
queen has for her son
the queen uh at this point in her life i
mean it is her son and she loves her
family and she's always found a way to
sort of differentiate between herself as
sovereign and herself as a mother and a
grandmother and sometimes that for her
has proved very very painful because she
said that things becoming conflict i
mean she she was ultimately had to deny
her sister margaret uh
you know the the the the love of her
life peter town in but when it comes
down to protecting the crown she's
always done that one final question for
you
we are as you said drawing towards the
end of the queen's reign
she has
lived longer than millions and millions
of her subjects most of us can't imagine
a world where she isn't there she almost
symbolizes britain and what britishness
is
how traumatic do you think it will be
for the country when
queen elizabeth is is no longer there
i think it will be
an absolutely pivotal moment in this
country i think that
the mourning will be intense and
uh
not only for this remarkable woman and
what she's been able to do
in her life for every day of her life
but also for a way
a way of britishness perhaps that she's
always epitomized
she has come to stand i think for all
the values that this nation holds dear
you know stoicism a sense of duty uh a
sense of fairness um a sense of doing
the right thing and to lose that i think
is going to be a traumatic event
well i think we're all dreading that
moment actually tina thank you so much
thank you beth um and i as i said i have
thoroughly enjoyed um this book which i
haven't quite finished because it's it's
big but it's good thank you for reading
i'm gonna i'm gonna get through it
thanks thanks for coming thank you thank
you so much
tina brown there well stay with us
because coming up next i've got gloria
allred the u.s attorney that has
dedicated her life to women's rights
[Music]
u.s attorney gloria allred has built her
career representing women and protecting
women's rights working with accusers of
r kelly harvey weinstein and bill cosby
this week a leak from the u.s supreme
court suggested that it could overturn
the case that legalized abortion
sparking outrage in the u.s earlier i
spoke to gloria about that case and she
told her own story about her abortion
gloria thank you so much
for talking today
let's focus on that bombshell leak from
the supreme court
were you shocked
well i was shocked by
the unprecedented leak of a draft
opinion from the u.s supreme court
we've never seen anything like this
before
but more importantly the shock was
that there is a majority on the u.s
supreme court who is not just going to
chip away at roe v wade
the 1973 united states supreme court
decision that found that women have a
constitutional right to legal and safe
abortions at least at certain stages of
their pregnancy but instead the majority
is going to strike it down completely
and this of course is catastrophic and
it's dangerous to the lives and the
health of women and gloria i wonder
actually when i s i saw the leak i
wondered whether it had been leaked
because people someone wanted it out
there in order to try and stoke up
enough
resistance that the leak document might
get changed to explain it to our viewers
is this the end of the constitutional
protection for abortion perhaps forever
or do you think that the leaked document
given the reaction in the us might get
changed
uh i think it's highly unlikely that the
decision of the majority will change
it's possible is it probable
not likely so we have to prepare
for the day
when we lose the constitutional right to
choose abortion and remembering the
victims who are going to be most at risk
and those are young women those are poor
women
those are women of color those are women
who are
rural women
and
those women are most vulnerable those
four categories because often they don't
have the money to travel to another
state in the united states like
california where i am now new york some
other states haven states where abortion
will remain legal because we are
pro-choice states and so they don't have
money to put gasoline in their car if
they even have a car or to buy a train
ticket or a bus ticket they don't have
money for child care to take care of
their other children while they travel
to get an abortion so this is mandatory
motherhood this is deciding that a
fertilized egg has more rights than an
adult woman and that is dangerous it is
wrong even teenagers who get pregnant
beth
and have their parents consent to get an
abortion in some of these states they
won't be able to get it
in some of these states they're even
outlawing medicaid uh medication
abortions meaning taking a pill in your
own home to self-induce an abortion
which is important because half of all
abortions in the united states are
medication abortions and they're
often to get the pill in the mail they
have to have a consultation with a
doctor online
telemedicine and many states are
outlawing that that's what's at stake um
can congress simply where do you go from
here can congress simply legislate to
replicate that constitutional protection
for women is that an option
yes beth and that's what the president
meant when he said it could be codified
the women's health protection act has
already been passed by the house of
representatives but we all know it's
unlikely to even be voted on by the
united states senate because they will
filibuster keep talking and not allow a
vote because many of the anti-choice
politicians are cowards and they don't
want people to know that they'll vote
against the women's health protection
act and so we have to fight you know who
knows maybe we're going to have to add
justices to the u.s supreme court um you
know we're going to have to also fight
state by state i wanted to talk to you
about your story actually um because
this is personal for you isn't it you
were one of those women
and now you're very very frightened
about this happening to other women can
you briefly tell us your story
i'm more than frightened i'm angry i'm
fired up and i'm ready to go to fight to
battle and i will be speaking at the uh
la city hall
uh rally on may 14th uh and they're
going to be rallies all over this
country uh pro-choice rallies in every
state on that date
yes it is personal for me uh because i
had to pay someone who was not licensed
to perform abortions after i was raped
at gunpoint in mexico when i was on
vacation there and returned to
california when i was in my 20s and
before roe v wade made abortion safe and
legal
and then
i had to
have an ambulance called be taken to the
hospital with 106 degree fever pact and
ice and that's where a nurse said to me
i hope this teaches you a lesson
meaning she was anti-choice it did teach
me a lesson but the lesson was that
abortion must be safe and legal and
affordable and available and that is why
i have been fighting
for pro-choice
laws and
to preserve roe v wade for
all of my professional life 47 years in
law practice and even before that and we
must protect because women will die and
will be maimed by illegal abortion or be
compelled to take pregnancies to term
when they're not ready and able uh uh to
support
uh a as a child that may be born so this
is a dangerous time and we must fight
back and just to pick up something you
said you you said that one option would
be to add justices
to the supreme court is that something
that president biden
could try to do how would that work
well you know that's that's an option
it's a very difficult one it's a very
controversial one
but you know these are
extreme times and uh
and we know that
and so you know i mean how extreme does
it get
how much more does it get when in some
states they're even
requiring rape victims children who are
victims of incest to give birth and not
be able to get an abortion
so you know we're going to explore all
options
all options are going to be on the table
yes this is radical as the president has
said and it is radicalizing women and
girls in this nation in the way it never
has before
so get ready we're going to be exploring
all options it's not going to be just an
academic task we are going to take to
the streets we are going to take to the
courts we are going to uh go in the
court of public opinion and we are going
to do everything that is legal and not
necessarily peaceful to win our rights
and we are going to get out the vote in
every election now uh and we are going
to vote because our lives depend on it
and that is why we will and
gloria just rode and wade roe versus
wade it seemed permanent i remember
studying it at school
uh it was past 49 years ago when you
were just a young woman did you ever
because i don't think i did did you ever
imagine it might be overturned and do
you see this as a colossal failure of
the american left of the woman's
movement do you must feel quite angry at
your country at the moment do you
well all i can say is
the anti-choice forces have not stopped
since roe v wade
in challenging it
they have filed many lawsuits some of
which have gone to the supreme court and
in every state
so they have been fighting they have
been shipping away
and now it's the ultimate time for them
uh they are people celebrating that they
get to control women and their choices
and their lives but we are going to show
them
that we have uh you know we have the
determination and the persistence we
will resist we will persist
and we will insist
that women's rights be respected
and i believe that we will win it will
be a battle but we
expect to and intend to
win this war against women thank you so
much gloria i really appreciated your
time thank you thanks for coming on the
show
anytime
well that's all for tonight's show thank
you to all our guests claire thrussell
tina brown and gloria allred and thank
you for watching
and if you scan the qr code on your
screen right now you can listen to the
beth rigby's interview podcast and new
episodes available now each week i take
a look at the highlights of the
interviews and there's some extra bits
in there too from me and my producer
molly malone that's on the sky news app
or wherever you get your podcasts
coming up on sky news at 10 as the polls
close i'll bring you the latest on the
local elections and the northern ireland
elections
[Music]